so you went to the Emmys for the first
time this year I I did as well it was my
first I saw you I know we didn't know
each other but I saw you well it was my
first time too I was a little nervous
because I never done that and it was a
long walk out very long time were you
did you have a good time I had a
wonderful time so I was there with my
best friend who's on uh rings of power
and he was presenting a smile and so we
had this incredible seat behind Oprah oh
baby baby I left my body it was crazy
she came out I've never seen a white
jumpsuit that white in my life
right there that's it oh oh y'all were
at the tables we were at the table
behind yes that's me contained I was
freaking out inside that's me really
trying to be cute but that white look at
that white you ain't never seen white
like that have you first of all she like
exudes that's a good look yeah yeah hey
is that a pink Watch series that pink
watch yes I'm actually wearing
everything oh man that's a good looking
glass uh black owned company spring
break watch yeah that's nice all right
here's what I was nervous about so I've
never done the image and I walk out and
then I was like oh no like I just come
from like a big huge truth that day it
was like I came straight from there for
another job there and and and I didn't
know all the tables were going to be
behind and I was like wait I made sure
the front looked good but I don't know
what the back looks like I was like I
was like oh it's a whole lot
you look better I was like well I don't
know but I definitely wasn't going to be
wearing white um
she looked beautiful so yeah
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]